I feel like my whole life since I shot
that has been I know well hell yeah I'm
so happy I had just lost a big fight to
cyborg Cris cyborg and I just totally
did not go as planned this is going to
be a decade ago this year I know what
decade yeah so then Steven Soderbergh
called
and he said we would like to kind of do
a movie a real life and you know action
movie with this you know fighter and
it's gonna happen really quick or it's
not gonna happen at all and it happened
I haven't like looked back since you
know I've just been paying my dues here
in this business and it hasn't
necessarily been I've had wonderful jobs
and I've had not so wonderful jobs but
to look back and say that I've been
doing this now for 10 years
mm-hmm it just now feels like it's
starting to click you did fast and
furious
Deadpool now you have the mandalorian
coming up what is that those kind of
pockets of fandom been like for you it's
been so I'm very like like I don't have
a lot of friends but no I'm kind of a
little bit shy ER and I don't like
expose myself like like open up my life
to just everyone so the MMA community
and like the Star Wars community opening
up their arms and like the Italian
community like they all are starting to
embrace me and I'm like damn it feels so
good to be a part of people you know it
feels so good to have people rooting for
you in a positive way and like
understanding and really hearing the
words that are coming out of your mouth
and when when you get involved in these
certain places as people open up their
ears and they're like no she's one of us
so we're gonna hold on to her and we're
gonna grow with her that's the best
looks like like Star Wars Celebration
for example I love going to that because
you're like I spend like my whole day on
Twitter calm and on the Internet yeah
and it can be like a lot of negativity
and then you have places like that where
everyone is just like yeah
lifting each other up hugging each other
I mean I've made some of my best friends
in my life at that amazing I thought it
was like it was like it was literally as
soon as we walked out on you know on
stage
was a rush of like this positive energy
which I was not expecting and I feel
like you know Twitter is like one of the
worst places to go but I refused to like
I refused to let people chase me away
you know or not and I refused to be one
of those negative negative voices like
I'm I feel like more people like us you
know probably need to speak up a little
bit more and not be like muffled by the
hate and like the destructiveness that
is out there as a lot of us have been
reserved and now we're like no one like
we're human beings you know we're just
trying to do the best we can you know
and so that that was just a positive
energy I love it yeah was that like a
dream casting for you
I mean are you kidding me I was like I
literally I mean there's been so Jon
Favreau is just you know you see all his
movies and you just think gosh what a
wonderful man you know he seems so cool
and all of his characters and every
scene that use anyways steals I feel and
like he looked at me before my big scene
one of my biggest introductory scenes in
the mandalorian and he was like we're
gonna change your trajectory right now
because he loved do you or no he just I
think that he's a very honest man and
he's seen the struggle and he's seen
what happens to careers and he's like
we're he's like we're gonna change your
path right now and like I was welling up
with tears just like and he was like
from here on from here on out you're
gonna choose jobs that are complementing
and you're gonna choose job side
challenging when you're gonna believe in
yourself and you know from this scene
forward and I went out and I crushed
that scene and it was like I seen that
when I first read the script I was like
oh gosh this is more than I've ever been
given how am I gonna do this now it's
like huh I'm just gonna say I can do it
why can't I do it and then with him you
know I've really trained for it and I
really like was president and I was just
looking at him and I was like he
believed in me and it helped me believe
in myself right just like the whole Lady
Gaga
Bradley Cooper thing it's kind of could
have 99 people in a room yeah one
believes in I'm telling you that I'm
telling you that's real yeah you can
look at one person and like they you can
make their whole entire life just you
know by believing them and he did that
for me and I couldn't thank them enough
because I feel like my whole life since
I shot that has been hell yeah
I'm still doing it it's getting better
and I'm so happy I've been in this a
long time now but I just never have
experienced my experience on the
mandalorian and it was just such a I
mean it really did I'm never gonna go
I'm never gonna go back like this is
what movie I'm making should be my
standard is like refreshed and renewed
and I'm really excited to see what the
next job isn't because I just I get it
now it clicked it finally clicked and I
feel like I've got a unique I've got a
unique voice in it I think people are
really going to receive like you know I
had Dave Filoni and John like they just
kept on saying oh my gosh people are
gonna love you
like people are gonna just love your
character yeah I am too and thank you
thank you for being excited too because
I can tell in your face that you're just
as excited and that like that makes me
feel like I'm going on the right path
right yeah so a hundred percent well
certainly back to daughter of the wolf
um you know we've seen you just like
kick so much ass in so many movies I
mean you get to punch Richard Dreyfuss
in the face no but it's really like he's
the sweetest I don't want to but I felt
like this one was moving towards like
you're wielding a weapon it's a little
more intimate what other types of roles
would you like to play in the future
like what you want to do like a rom-com
or something like oh my gosh get me and
I like get me in a rom-com I just feel
like I come to life and it's all my
favorite all my favorite movies are like
that like you know my natural-born
killers and like you know just like
crazy psychotic love stories where like
two people just like can't have enough
of each other and it's them against the
world I mean that that would be amazing
so you know I'm down with that and I'm
done with you know a genuine like real
life story of you know struggle and you
know I think that I do really well in
that space because I am honest and so I
think that I could really portray like
somebody's real life story very honestly
so it'll be really it's gonna be really
interesting what happens next
I'm not sure what it's gonna be we've
said no to a couple of stuff because
like John farboro told me you know we're
going a different direction now and I
believe it so it's gonna know what's
gonna happen I am so excited for you I'm
your biggest supporter probably right
under John Favreau
Thank You daughter of the wolf is in
select theaters and on VOD now go check
it out
Gina's in it and a lot more coming next
thank you thank you so much